amber heard faces cameras for the first
time since her defamation trial defeat
welcome to entertainment tonight
nichelle turner is off it's been 12 days
since the verdict handed her ex-husband
johnny deppa decisive victory now amber
is speaking out about the fight she
still faces in the court of public
opinion
there's no polite way to say it the jury
looked at the evidence you presented
they listened to your testimony and they
did not believe you
they thought you were lying how could
they not come to that conclusion they
had sat
in those seats
and heard through over three weeks
of non-stop relentless testimony
from paid
employees
and towards the end of the trial randos
as i say
so you don't blame the jury i don't
blame them i actually understand he's a
beloved character
and people feel they know him he's a
fantastic actor
bring me that horizon
even if you think that i'm lying you
still couldn't look me in the eye and
tell me that you think on social media
there's been a fair representation you
cannot tell me
that you think that this has been fair
in the sit-down which airs in three
parts starting tomorrow on the today
show with more friday on dateline amber
reportedly takes a swipe at johnny's
courtroom fans calling them depford
wives but there's one question why sit
down with savannah guthrie who just last
week before interviewing johnny's
attorneys revealed this the quick
disclosure my husband has done
consulting work for the deaf legal team
but not in connection with this
interview savannah's husband michael
feldman is a public relations and
communications consultant it is believed
savannah shot the sit-down last thursday
the same day amber was spotted flying to
and from new york in a private jet a
source tells e.t amber was advised to
lay low and take time for herself before
speaking out we're also told amber is
confident that her side will come out
eventually she has a plan and strategy
to make a comeback over the next year
the actress is rumored to be working on
a tell-all memoir the 36-year-old took
frequent notes during the trial and her
so-called love journal documenting her
volatile relationship with johnny was
entered as evidence
in another wild twist johnny could take
the stand in his own defense in a civil
trial in la in just 42 days according to
court documents obtained by e.t the
actor will be represented by camille
vasquez the breakout star from his
defamation trial
this man location manager greg brooks is
suing depp for allegedly hitting him on
set while they were working on the movie
city of lies